we have now learned that Donald Trump's
first criminal trial we don't know if
there will be more than one we will see
Trump's first criminal trial has been
set for March of 2024 and this is going
to be taking place right in the middle
of the 2024 presidential election right
when the um Republican electorate may be
choosing or close to choosing their
nominee for 2024 and this could be
absolute and total chaos this Republican
primary is already going to be I believe
the most insane I will have ever covered
with Ron DeSantis announcing tonight
that he is entering the race Trump
already massively triggered by that news
I believe that this is going to be a
completely Bonkers primary
it could become even Crazier by what we
learned from CNN yesterday A New York
judge has set a trial date of March 25
2024 for the criminal case against
former president Donald Trump
potentially setting up a media spectacle
in the middle of the Republican primary
yeah I think it's more than just the
potential to create a spectacle the
trial date was set during a brief
hearing Tuesday in which the judge read
Trump in order on what he can and cannot
say publicly about the case I'm sure
Trump is going to abide by that right
Trump appeared remotely via video feed
so the judge could communicate with him
in open court remember that Trump
pleaded not guilty last month the 34
felony counts we talked about that we
covered it live during the hearing Trump
could be seen speaking and gesturing to
his attorney Todd Blanche sitting next
to him but audio was not audible at
times he sat back with his arms crossed
the former president only spoke to
confirm he had a copy of the protective
order yes I do he said Trump's attorney
said that the former president remains
concerned that the order infringes on
his first amendment rights quote he
understands he has to comply with the
order and if he doesn't do so he's
violating your order
Merchant reiterated that's the judge
that there is not a gag order in place
Trump can publicly defend himself
against the allegations saying it is
certainly not my intention to impede
Trump's ability to campaign for
president he's free to defend himself
he's free to campaign he is free to do
just about anything that does not
violate the specific terms of the
protective order and said if he does
violate that order he could end up being
sanctioned this is going to be
completely bonkers the next hearing is
January for so the timeline is as
follows defense motions are due a couple
of days before the end of August
prosecutors must respond by the 10th of
October the next hearing is January 4th
2024 which might be the first court date
of 2024 January 4th no that's a Thursday
um and then this is all going to uh move
forward to trial reportedly in March now
there is one motion filed by Trump's
lawyers which could completely upend
this Trump's lawyer this is from the
same CNN article Trump's lawyers have
filed a motion to move the criminal case
to Federal Court
arguing that these crimes are tied to
Trump's duties as president the defense
request to move the case to Federal
Court doesn't pause the state Court's
schedule a hearing in federal court is
scheduled for next month
so this there are so many ifs ands and
buts about when and how this is actually
going to go forward if it does get moved
to federal court it's going to be a
completely different situation that then
we will have to potentially have a new
schedule from the ground up if this
schedule remains
this could end up all leading to a trial
of former president Donald Trump a
criminal trial on 34 felony counts as
mathematically Trump is locking up the
Republican nomination or maybe not right
the question is if Trump does get
arrested again sometime between July and
September by Fannie Willis and maybe
there will be more charges coming from
the Mar-A-Lago uh documents Fiasco on
and on
this may this may destroy Trump's
chances even beforehand but imagine that
things stay as they look right now Trump
with an easy lead over Ron DeSantis but
Ron DeSantis stays in maybe even wins a
couple primaries maybe DeSantis wins the
Florida Republican primary and a couple
others in March March into April when
this trial may be happening
the guy who is on trial for 34 criminal
counts could at that exact same time be
securing the Republican nomination what
will that be like I don't know
completely unprecedented and at this
point we will wait and see whether the
trial is moved to Federal Court